hé, quel est ton marché, je me suis
beaucoup amusé,
je n'ai pas besoin de lotion là-dedans ouais tu as
besoin de lotion là-dedans nous recherchons
un artisan de la cour pour faire du travail sur nos
buissons j'ai travaillé sur d'
autres  les buissons vous donnent vraiment envie de
frapper vos mauvaises herbes j'étais plus sale que je ne le
pensais je suis désolé je me suis sali très
vite maman et papa ont vendu la maison de notre enfance
cela aurait dû être transmis tout ce que nous avons
besoin que vous fassiez est de nettoyer votre chambre
oh boy  c'est vraiment dommage que tu n'aies jamais
passé ta nuit ici on ne peut pas faire la
fête tu ne peux bien sûr pas deux ans tu
ne peux pas éviter de te mettre dehors
pour toujours ne me travaille pas comme ça il y a
tellement de choses à faire tu dois inviter ça
mec mignon du bout de la rue
salut je suis Maura je suis James je voulais juste
dire bonjour donc c'est
fait  obtenir cette robe une de mes
pommes continue de sortir du sac j'aime l'
histoire qu'elle raconte avec la frange oh elle  e
on y va je pense pourquoi tu ne
boiras pas ce soir
pour que je puisse laisser voler mon drapeau monstre j'adorerais
j'ai entendu dire que tu organisais une fête
de quelqu'un qui a été invité c'est assez
triste ceinture
snazzy oh merci ouais félicitations pour ta
lutte  championnat nous devons dire
au revoir à cette maison mais nous nous sommes bien
amusés tu es le genre de dur à cuire auquel
je suis susceptible disons pour
continuer juste dans
la zone où ils se tiennent
oh c'est ma boîte à musique de ballerine
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une belle mélodie et bizarre non